so now it was my understanding that you
watched literally every anime
no actually in that case my
understanding was incorrect
yeah so where did you get that
understanding where did you get that was
it from my name
when i first met you i remember you
being like yeah
every anime well yeah
[Laughter]
well that was also during a way to help
me out like that that was also
i'm sorry i'm sorry sorry sorry i'm
sorry no no but like i think because
when i did meet you
it was like what 2015 2016 right back
then i literally did watch
everything but that's because that was
also the time when
i also wasn't as busy as i was now okay
like i think the one reason i just can't
anymore it's because i just have
so much [ __ ] going and i was wondering
how you managed to maintain
that level of sitting on a couch when
you're doing so many things
right like oh by the way i watched the
video of you guys riding bicycles across
japan oh yeah
it's very clear to oh god
that's wonderful wonderful it was a
masterpiece um but i was wondering how
you managed to keep
up that level of consumption when your
output was so great this is he doesn't
i don't he does this is interesting
i think one of the interesting things
about becoming content
is the lifestyle that is required to be
content is the opposite of the lifestyle
required to consume content
yeah 100 100 i'd agree with that and i
think
the best way the best like uh metaphor i
guess for it
is to think about professional sports
the lifestyle of the guys on the field
is the polar opposite from the lifestyle
that people understand
even the stands with their beer and
their hot dogs swearing swearing and
screaming
yeah guys in the field getting up at 5am
and doing sprints right right but salad
i feel that's the same way when you're
doing content it's like you say what you
got into it
as a consumer you then become the
content right
and now you are to be consistent that's
the problem right then and that's i
guess the dilemma
right well i mean exactly but like
that's also just the dilemma of being
an anime content creator right it's like
i need to watch anime
to create content but because i'm too
busy creating content i don't have time
to watch androids
it's it's the catch 22. it's the catch
22. exactly and i've just been trying so
hard to i guess like just try and keep
up
as much as possible but without having
to go down to like
a video every two months right so it's
just like call me out
well no you're getting way better at a
recently yeah you're getting way better
recently right like we're all
slow with your uploads yeah i mean like
i my upload schedule is like way longer
than either of these two
but uh i mean that's because but they
also like packs captioning not
and we available like a tier list oh
yeah and uh he turned on the camera we
just started talking for an hour and a
half turns it off and he goes all right
done my work here is that i'm just like
what
yeah just send it to my editor now we're
good
those are the rare instances where
you're like this is just amazing because
i got one of my weekly uploads done in
an hour yeah and it required no planning
but then other times it's like i have to
set up so many [ __ ] things
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i got to go to x
time with x person
film this blah blah blah permission yeah
absolute nightmare sometimes
um so how did this transition happen
from doing anime content
into your going out into the world and
doing interesting japan things content
i think i don't know i don't know about
you jay but i never wanted to be stuck
in my room doing stuff but
it's like it's the means that you have
at that time right it's like when i was
creating content i always envisioned
something
bigger that was you know more involved
with me doing stuff
and moving to japan yeah agency health
was pretty much the key to allowing me
to do that
i think i think for me it was more so
because you know i have
the problem with my name being the anime
man people just expect me to just be
every video i'm in my room talking about
anime so
i always because i always had like so
many ideas to do other things that
no matter how much i thought about it i
was like there's no way i can twist
anime into this so i might as well just
not make it
but then this year especially i was like
oh [ __ ] it
like if i enjoy it and it just seems
interesting enough and i can you know
have a fun time doing it then
i'm just gonna make